hey everyone it's my kobato's and
welcome to the Oder phones market
analysis for Wednesday August 16 2017
now the big thing on the calendar today
was the FOMC minutes and yeah they came
out and they didn't specifically say if
the Fed would begin shrinking its
balance sheet this year really that
that's what the market was really
waiting to see if the Fed was going to
start reducing the balance sheet soon
and you know so now the market sees
reduced chance for December rate hike
you know again never before people are
talking about one more hike this year
right now it's kind of toned down now
the next big thing Thursday is the ECB
yet it has their minutes coming out so
we'll see we'll see I mean there's been
signs lately of the euro eurozone
economy gathering pace in the second
quarter so email policymakers they're
been signaling they're getting closer to
phasing out quantitative easing which is
going on for years but anyway let's jump
into it first a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only it should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures trading could contain
substantial risk is not for every
investor an investor could potentially
lose all on more than the initial
investment risk capital is money that
could be lost not jeopardizing one's
financial security or lifestyle only
risk capital should be used for trading
and only those with sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results
okay the tools used in this presentation
are the order flows trader and the Delta
scalper dealer flow trader is the volume
footprint chart and the Delta a scalper
is an additional order flow trading tool
okay so you know it's you know FOMC
minutes came on today so I kind of had a
feeling the market was going to be kind
of quiet and it was most of the morning
I mean when I say the markets I'm
talking about the bonds and the equities
so you know a cash open we're trading
around 24 69 in that area in here 69 and
a half just off our highs and for the
next couple hours we just sort of rotate
it around you know didn't get up to the
high didn't get down
though we just traded basically I felt
around 67 and and 70 and you see just
going back and forth back and forth is
848 you know finally around 9:30 we
started making these highs you know an
hour after the cash open so we can add a
high come out pick out the high again
take out the high and then 10 o'clock
when we got divergence you've got the
Delta scalper and then look at this
strong negative deltas 872 two thousand
thirteen hundred and the markets coming
off now you know another sign you know
that this is high is getting kind of
weak up here that we could possibly sell
off as this bar here when we hit the
high again you have small Delta 42 right
we get very small Delta might as well be
a negative Delta for all intents and
purposes so you got strong Delta nine
eighty eight eight forty nine still
strong it's a little weaker but 42
definitely weak and then obviously a new
high you put in with the negative Delta
but more importantly the next bar after
that very very strong negative Delta
minus 2000 sort of lights out at this
point but again you know Delta scalpers
picking it up early that is changing up
here already and you know you sell off
from the 70 you know one and a half area
72 down to 69 then you rally back up
make a new high this at this time it's
times at here 11 to 1 11:28 and you know
kind of you know is interesting is
there's a coming up here right you had
three in a row which to me is a bullish
sign looking for the pullback between
these two points controllers you don't
get it here instead you get this doji
bar okay so I'm kind of off this already
but again you know I'm not necessarily
big fan of three in a row going into a
higher or a cell going into a low but
nevertheless you know ideal entry is
going to be between these pointed
controls and it should be coming in this
bar yeah technically it got in got
within the point control here then what
happens and watch this Delta 4,000
strong
1000 still strong 119 weak 1,300 weak
2,000 obviously weak but you picking it
up
in the turn here you're picking up the
Delta scalper giving you a cell right
here you've got a ratio as well and then
what happens again you sell off again
from the 71 and a half area down back
down to the 16 video below 69 area down
in here where you get the Delta Center
you get a stacking balance you know then
you're at this point you got another
three in a row here you don't get to
pull back either right it's a three in a
row cell you go out to green bar here if
you want to here not here you don't get
to pull back between here you don't get
the entry that you're looking for now
I'm not saying that you know I would
play it come all the way back up here
you know how many bars later no I want
the bar to come right after the three in
a row it just sort of goes side at this
point you know if you're coming in 12:30
you know you got minutes coming out at
one o'clock so you know you be careful
about taking any trades one o'clock
market gets to catch the bid when the
minutes come out we shoot up Delta
scalper there it comes right up where
you got the stacks on a balance hanging
in there it's hanging in there it's
holding again inside this initial sound
and balance you got more imbalances here
one - so you got stacks down and
balanced here then you come right back
up you got selling and balance almost a
stacks on a balance again but still the
selling coming in at that same level and
then the market sells off you know then
just sort of rotates around the opening
price and until the close here now at
the other market you know you're not
looking at the ten range S&P chart not
much to go off of honestly let me just
pull it up really quick here
and the one thing that I love looking
for for okay so again you know we had
made our high we added divergence up
here at 10:14 nothing else telling you
to get short here we finally come back
up make the new I use is the price
rejecter start selling off then after
one o'clock you get these bars here all
right you get one two three buying
imbalances met with one two three four
selling a balance I love it when you get
multiple imbalances in a bar normally I
would find this bullish let's not
immediately bearish and then more
bearish coming in right here with others
multiple imbalances in this bar and then
you see we just sell we sell off over
the next two bars as well so as you know
part of the reason you had that I think
is just because you know I said one
o'clock yet the minutes come out so
volumes a little bit thinner than normal
here at this time so it spikes up here
and it was not enough volume being
transacted then we close this bar pretty
quick and the selling came in
immediately right after that so I like
this bar shot up very fast that kinda
came back down really fast you know this
bar formed very quickly and we got into
the next butter very fast and you see
more cell and and balances here so I
know sellers are definitely in control
at this point and you can take it in
this next bar here for you know about
four points three points four points now
bonds and bonds most of the morning
we're pretty quiet but I thought about
five years five years you know is again
a classic classic trade setup something
that I talk about daily every single day
you know it's not rocket science right
but you know this is it right here so
we're rallying you get these filled ok
go back a little bit here on the 5s ok
so this morning five in the morning
ratio and divergence delta scalpel right
after yeah market start is trying to
poke up it's trying to hook up any but
just go sideways sideways a little bit
higher okay so maybe you could scout
that for you know a couple of ticks
three or four ticks hopefully this
morning before it shot up I mean but
again I'm not saying you get long at
5:30 in the morning here we hold it in
until 9:00 of course not but you know in
there are people that will I know that
so anyway we started rolling this is one
o'clock here so minutes come out new
high new high then you get up here is
what gets interesting you got the high
you got right off the high to Delta
scalper in a variation now again is the
same thing in the in the ESP s as you
saw earlier right you get up to the high
Delta scalper coming in right off the
highlight I love selling you cause say
all year you're trying to pick highs no
I'm not I'm letting the market tell me
there's a high being made here okay then
you can react you know Delta scalper
coming in here does it sell off
initially just kind of go sideways or
then you get the little push lower so
you get a move from like 13 and a half
down to 12 you know this is decent in
the fives it's about six ticks but I
mean you see it just as you saw it in
the SPS you're coming up here towards
the high gets sort of weakening Delta
six 72 136 152 and strong negative Delta
and then in this case it sort of trades
Delta back and forth positive negative
positive negative you know strong strong
strong strong but still overall net net
selling you know right off this high I
mean that's what you want to be picking
up you want to be picking up signs of
the market shifting you know off of a
high you know that that is changing from
a demand driven market to a supply
driven market and once it's shifts to a
supply driven market it's going to sell
off that's what that's what markets do
right when it's driven by supply they
sell off when it's different driving by
demand they rally ok this is crude oil
talk about crude for a while I haven't
talked about crew for a bit but you know
coming into the morning session again
it's going to be the roll period for
crude so if you don't have October up
you could be tracking it as well like I
think tomorrow will probably change days
from Thursday already but anyway you saw
that decent volume today in the
except well anyway uh words that I want
to talk about okay so here you got a
7:30 racial divergence that failed then
you get down here to this low you've got
a point of control towards the bottom
that's just this is blue hash again you
don't need that but you know I just use
that as my own visual reference and then
we rally up rally up really up
okay so 9:30 we at the end the towing
numbers came out and so I got a little
bit of a push up here it wasn't a big
big big move it's kind of muted today it
was about what is that about fifteen
twenty seven move sometimes we get as
much as a buck but anyway we got up here
put a control right on the extreme right
on the high racial bounds low buying
balance up on the high you've got you
know divergence period in here you got
to delt the scalper coming in here and
you know we sell off from this high you
know down to you know the fifty area
then we started rotating around rotating
around we hit the new low we've got
again point of control towards the
bottom we've got divergence divergence
but well look at the volume right 322
next time you trade down there 63 so you
got less volume and it's just looking at
these volumes it's a bit less or 63 oh
here's for 28 years 206 you know 267 295
whatever but more importantly at the
bottom you got lesser volume going
through at the bottom side here so you
know it's usually good for a little bit
of a pop up in the sense that you know
there's a lack of selling going down
into this low the second time you hit it
right always people I talk about double
bottom so you know how to trade double
bottoms well here if you use an order
flow you can see what the volume was
that second time you hit that low it's a
bit less and we start a rally but we
just mostly go sideways eventually we
get this some buying comes in here you
got that stacked imbalance and you know
we go all the way up into the into the
80s up in here okay then we start
selling off again down into the new low
so you got those
divergences from earlier another failed
divergence you already got to refill
divergences I'd be looking for a sign
you know if we're going to come on to
this low you know possibly getting short
and you get it again so you know if
you're getting short around 32
immediately trades right down straight
down to 22 even lower lower lower down
to 16 down here new lows out here you've
got a divergence and the ratio or
afterwards Delta scalper coming in does
it rally next bar up and then just sort
of go sideways on you over the next
several bars before coming down making a
new low but again you know you got you
know failed divergences one two and then
a third one here at this point I'm
looking for this market to go lower
already so again you know I mean it's
pretty safe short at 30 you know trades
down to you know blow 20 even eventually
goes a little bit lower but I'm not sure
I would have I'd be looking to hold it
that much lower we take and be happy
with a quick 10 ticks another ratio and
another ratio on divergence is similar
to trade here right racial divergence
Delta scalper ratio the divergence ratio
and Delta scalper again a little
short-lived rally and then you come back
in taking out the lows again boom so you
got a lot of failed divergences you know
that to me that's a sign of the market
that's trending you know I'd be looking
to get short again even if you're
getting short around 10 area booms very
very fast down into the 80s get down
into the 80s got no divergence this time
here you got divergence Delta scope or
fails guys assess aspects on imbalance
there and we're still going a little bit
lower a little bit lower tick and lower
kick and lower tick and lower into the
close so you've had you know you had
some decent opportunities to get short
you know the one we've taken off these
loads that we're going to go lower you
know last thing you want to do is yeah
take out a low like this and just sort
of hang around here for the next you
know for you know for the rest of the
day but being on the trend a day that's
trending you know day that you have a
strong trend movement underway you're
going to get failed divergences this is
the reality of it so if you start seeing
fail divergences early you know it's a
sign you know don't be sitting here
kicking yourself all I got failed
divergence order flow Trading sucks
because every time I have a divergence
market
really know if they're failing you fade
it right you got you got 1 2 3 happening
in quick succession the markets going
lower markets trending but go with it
you know I mean being a good trader is
being able to adjust right to the
environment on what's going on yeah in
normal market conditions you have
divergences the market should rally or
sell-off you know independent to buying
divergence or selling divergence but
when you start getting multiple
divergences that are failing chances are
you're in a trending market go with it
go with the trend it one says the trend
is your friend so you got failed
divergences go with them okay this is
the euro currency 6e and going I want to
talk about here okay so here the same
thing I just showed you in the crude
right low 21
lakhs traded second time for lots traded
so it sounds a lot less right and to me
that's a nice sign that's a sign that
you know selling into this low is is
getting weaker and what do we do we
rally are you really from oh five all
the way up into the 20s going on barely
20s eventually got back up there Delta
scalp herself but then you know didn't
work out but Delta scalper by this one
was was a nice one you know went up here
got up here you got these trap traders
up here in this bar market sells off and
you get some trapped traders down here
Delta scalper given this cell right here
before you go over the next couple bars
a bit lower this Delta scalper didn't
work out just sort of went sideways I
knew it did go lower but just mostly
went sideways before the market rallied
here coming up you know you got some
nice aggressive buying now here you got
Delta scalper and stacking balance this
one didn't work out normally I like that
but it comes back with a stacking
balance going in the opposite direction
and really quick you know within two
bars which for me is a strong sign and
unfortunately the market just one
sideways here you know coming up on
o'clock here you see the liquidity is
drying up already right before the
minutes come out minutes come out and
it's just you know very thin volume
going through you see these a lot of
zeros
there's just nothing going through at
this time let's put the market
settle down a bit you know you could
sort of see how the volume is you know
37 in a bar you know which is nothing
you know too 90s all right 300 or 800
getting the settling down now you know
liquidity is coming back into the market
and you get up here you've got you know
got the red arrow telling you to get
short you know the next couple bars it
sells off from 90 down into the mid-80s
rallies back up there's a delta scalper
next bar is lower next two bars are
lower and I just sort of go sideways
works its way back up here you got some
trapped traders in this bar you can see
it right there it's pretty obvious
market sells off from you know the 95
area down into the 80s mid 80s but
really the key takeaway that I want to
show you what's that low when you get
the less volume
you know people there's going to be
examples where it's like you know 21 and
the next one is 18 is it less
technically yeah but it mean when it's
out quite obvious I mean you know the
zero currency right sometimes you don't
have a lot of volume blowing through so
you gotta take the numbers you know what
they're showing you but I mean people
say well 21 and four you know those are
small numbers anyway yeah they are but
you know normal detail previous bars you
put it in lows with 25 and with it with
18 you know with 23 so you know you got
to take everything in context of the
market okay just really quick the
obligatory beautiful charts in the Delta
scalper five-minute chart euro currency
since around the euro currency not much
signals today so what do you got here -
in the morning they got a sell didn't
work out it stopped the audit rally
and then boom you get to sell here at
11770 trades right down to 30 over the
next 15 minutes for working its way back
up and then what do you get here lo and
behold you get a buy one 1715 and what
does it do it shoots up to 117 90 now
and I just go sideways now is every
chart gonna be as beautiful as this no
right like I said it's the obligatory
beautiful five-minute chart let me see
if I got on say I shouldn't show that to
people because they'll see that and
everyone will get a [__] hard-on and
thinking you know this is the greatest
thing let's see here's a five-minute
five-year chart you get some nice
movements here too honestly I don't
usually look at five-minute okay this is
three of the mornings kind of choppy in
here but you know once the US Open
you know then the liquidity really
really picks up immensely you getting
some nice moves there let's see what
other charts I could show you maybe
something not as pretty I'm trying to
show minute based charts okay excuse me
got this sore throat
at the end again it's really quick as
yen five-minute chart does that sell up
there but I was about it nothing nothing
major you know by here around the same
time the euro currency then a buying a
cell here that didn't work out nothing
on this major move there people know
you've missed this move well the reason
in this the movies because there's
nothing in the Delta that was actionable
you know people think oh why doesn't it
give me a buy here well it's because the
market is set up the way it's supposed
to that's why it's not happening you
know it's not some magic elixir that's
going to conform the market into you
know the way you would want it this is a
soybean five-minute chart you know I
mean honestly our is every day as nice
as as it was today with five minutes
charts no but you know it's just
interesting I hear you got a nice pie
9:23 up at 9:26 this one is you know
right ahead of the reopen so you get the
signal right before they reopen I don't
think you'd be interested in taking that
but nevertheless throw it in there so
let's see how these ways much though I
want to go over those 233 tick charts
again and then the four range the four
range mini Dow so does he has DAC
anything interesting not really known as
that kind of quiet here early on in the
session what do you got okay so since
8:30 this morning when the cash opened
up I got the sell now that we're going
to get a nice little buy their nice
little sell and I shall go buy this one
doesn't work out that one doesn't work
out it'll sell here
these not get much out of not getting
much out of and you can nice move here
then after one o'clock is just going to
kind of quiet not much you get it by
there take a look at the crude again
honestly I think personally I think a
233 tick chart is is kind of fast you
need some sort of automation so what do
you get here and indecent moves yeah you
get a lot it moves actually here I was
too fast for me but the if I was a
broker I'd recommend it because they are
you big trading shitload a sell buy sell
buy sell buy so I mean it depends you
know I think if you're looking to get a
few ticks out of each trade yeah maybe
you should be looking at two thirty
three ticks charge I mean I see you know
some trades if I give up 15 to 20 ticks
but I don't know what the averages I
just like to look at these because
there's that guy gave me such a [__]
hard time about this indicator and in
the end I just refunded his money rather
than deal with them so this is my way to
spite him show them these charts that
look you know these are the charts that
he trades but it's just you know
ridiculous I mean sometimes you know
people want an indicator to give me a
cell here give me a buy here give me a
cell here give me a buy here give me so
it doesn't work that way right it reads
the Delta okay and if there's nothing in
the Delta up here to tell you to get
short it's not going to give you a
signal period I don't know I understand
why people don't understand that yeah
but it sometimes everyone wants every
single turning-point didn't give me a
cell here I missed this move well yeah
not everything is gonna give you a
[__] cell here right sorry but you
know just it just you sometimes you know
people's expectations don't conform with
reality but and again you know this is a
nice little chart if you're a short-term
trader if your dome trader and you're
looking to scalp a few ticks out of
every trade you know this is something
you get a few ticks here a few ticks
here if you ticks here here
here here almost out of every single
trade you get something maybe this one
no but definitely all this stuff 1 2 3 4
you got four winning trades right there
you know even here boom I mean look at
that cells off cells off cells off
rallies anyway again you know if you're
just someone looking for the next few
ticks in the market this is definitely
something you should consider you know
and lastly we'll take a look at this for
range chart in the mini Dow you know
boom boom boom boom you know here giving
you some nice cells here you know from
60 down into the 20s you know again from
60 down into the 40s those are nice
moves again you know boom boom boom boom
boom so yeah I mean canape can can it be
used with four range charts automatic
for range is very fast but yes it can be
used with four range charts just as I
show you what eight ranges as I show you
with many other types of charts
anyway anyway learn is for today that's
enough I covered a lot so thanks for
watching this to learn more about order
flows visit my website order flows at
Cana or visit the Delta scalper a
special right now if you buy the order
flow software I'll throw in the Delta
scalper for free normally it sells for a
few hundred bucks
but you'll get it for free when you buy
the main order flow software so thanks
everyone and have a good day bye bye